oh god that's bad oh god this is gross I
believe I am taste testing popsicles and
trying to guess the flavor I think I'm
gonna mix up the blue and red those are
my favorite they actually hate popsicles
like honestly they're not they're not a
thing for me it's not gonna be a dirty
trick right it's not gonna be a dirty
trick right if you didn't have teeth
this will be a treat what are these oh
dear these do not look cute I know this
is some bullet this ain't no red is no
blue ain't no green this better not be a
Crunchwrap supreme like in popsicle form
I'll be very sad it'll ruin it for me No
Oh little a salty Oh smells a bit like
dog food
Oh God I already think it's McDonald's
[Music]
there's the birthing over-rotated my
life that's bread oh I do think it's
McDonald's though it has that like
McDonald's stank on it and oh I it
should not be in that form Oh
chick-fil-a I'm gonna say my final
answer is chicken nuggets from
McDonald's this tastes like chicken
tenders I'll say chick-fil-a I'm going
for this one
I'm intrigued by the color cuz it's
definitely like a richer nicer brown
than the others which is interesting to
me and this sounds like a nice shade of
brown like a caramel brown pretty sure
it's not gonna be caramel dough very sad
this is really hard for me guys
that's kicked Oh
[Music]
how do people eat this a non blended for
Oh God and that's bad I have no idea
what this is
oh god this is so bad
[Music]
that's guard we thought it would that is
I'm not eating my McDonald's McDonald's
is trash
that's weak no that's a taco yeah it's
talked about I've had these I've gotten
these smells I have no idea so I'm just
gonna stick to like some sort of burrito
from like Chipotle some sort of Mexican
fast food place that's tunkel Bell it's
Taco Bell I I got like the taste of the
meat as it was at the very end as it
goes down my throat that is Taco Bell
holy this is gross
this one has no scent which maybe I'm
excited about which means maybe the
flavor is not as nasty as the others I
want one of these to be fried chicken
[Music]
tastes like nothing
okay I got taste there's one just
discussed out of what this one is maybe
this is like chicken nugget tortilla El
Pollo Loco just like no flavor to this
Nick fries I'm gonna sadly say this is
from McDonald's as well I don't want to
keep taking bites but maybe this is
fried chicken and it's just like I don't
know it's not pleasant but it's
definitely not like a burger that has a
lot of stuff on it it's one thing I
think this is chicken but it flavorless
chicken but my guess had been like KFC
oh oh god this is gross this is like a
cheeseburger Lou this is a spicy spicy
chicken right here I'm gonna say Wendy's
has like a Wendy's spicy chicken
Oh Donald I'm gonna think it's a
cheeseburger from McDonald's that ones
McDonald's it tastes like McDonald's
like pickles and onions and I'm 99% sure
this is McDonald's but now I don't know
what this one is and I'm really scared
to taste it again because it's a bit
like vomit
and I don't think I can go down that
road because I will vomit you know this
is horrible yeah I'm so bad outside of
it is what this chick-fil-a oh okay okay
oh wow okay okay I love chick-fil-a but
never would have guessed Wow I was kind
of close yeah heck yeah it's funny
because you can't taste it at first but
when it goes down your throat you like
get that meat saucy probably some ground
beef in there a couple spices okay
I mean I don't know if I would be happy
if I would guess all of these right
because it's such a weird challenge
what's the heck I've let my people down
if any if I got any of them right it
should have been Panda Express honestly
okay I was not even thinking that far
what I thought I'd be able to taste that
I'm shocked this one is like the
craziest one out of all of them because
there's no flavor I swear to God just
tastes like nothing
mmm okay I mean I'm not surprised there
I really taste it like a burger really
tasted the beef and the cheese which is
so nasty like I would never in my life
wanted to eat this in popsicle form mmm
that makes sense no it smells like Max
is a Big Mac sauce yeah I'm very proud
of myself
these thrill is a very spot on this one
who knew I feel like my work here is
done except I got one wrong yeah I would
never eat fast food in popsicle form
again because I didn't even want to do
this one I was tricked into this so I
hope you guys are happy this is a
horrible challenge I'm mad you guys even
doing this this is sick this was
revolting
and I never wanted to do anything like
this again I don't think that was that
bad
Oh Oh weak sauce oh no did you fly one
is by far the worst it's not that bad
talk about was be worse do you guys
wanna try it
[Music]